turn on to desert inn
as that bus made that turn
uh that bus came into contact with an
adult female
who's whose identity is unknown at this
point uh
struck that female as she was in the
roadway
and uh
unfortunately the the female did not
survive that collision
we do have uh we do have a number of
witnesses who have stood by and who are
helping us to determine exactly how this
happened
and we also the the bus driver
remained on scene has been cooperative
with the investigation at this point we
do not believe that speed or impairment
are factors involved in this crash
and we are also
working with the school district
for possible videos from the buses do we
know if the pedestrian was in a
crosswalk uh we don't know exactly at
this point where
where the pedestrian was in the roadway
and so that's what we're trying to
determine and hopefully
with the videos that we're able to
obtain either from the businesses in the
area or with the help of the school
district we'll be able to determine that
do school buses have cameras
some of them do some of them don't from
my understanding is i believe the
majority of them have internal cameras i
believe some of the newer buses have
external cameras
and so we're trying to determine uh
which buses in the area at the time that
this happened that we're able to draw
information from which west was it
uh it was the the bus involved in the
wreck was this one right here one six
five four four were there
there were there were at the time there
were three uh young children about
elementary school age um fortunately we
were able to get a hold of their parents
and they've been released to their
parents and no children were hurt no
trailer hurt in this again
because the bus driver was going from a
stop position on warnock making a
right-hand turn onto desert inn
obviously in a school bus it'd be hard
to to build up any type of speed that
would
create circumstances where either
through the collision or through braking
would uh would cause serious injury or
harm to anybody on the bus we had a
witness tell us that the pedestrian was
drugged under the bus for several feet
is that something you can confirm that's
that's information uh that's information
we're trying to that's going to be a
part of the investigation
um
because um
it's clear that we can see that the
subject is still on scene unfortunately
and um we can see how far up from that
intersection that subject is and so
that's going to be part of our
investigation is to find out exactly
where
uh that that
lady was or where that female was at the
time that she she
had that collision with the bus
what is the driver said about why this
happened
at this point the driver was doing what
she usually does you know she
she was stopped at the intersection
watching for traffic so that she could
safely move out into the roadway and
she tried to make the turn when she
thought she could safely do so
and you said neither speed nor
impairment or neither no not at this
point and how hard is it to see another
situation like this we've talked about
in the past how you know a lot of these
situations can be prevented and even if
they can't it's just really difficult to
see for you and for the people involved
it's
well
it comes down to a number of factors um
you know what uh when this happened at 3
41 you know we're coming into the latter
part of the year where you know you've
got the sun setting in the west if
you're making a turn to the west if
you're looking to the west you know your
vision may not be
as good looking as if you were looking
to the east because the sun's in your
eyes
what i tell people whether you're
driving a car driving a vehicle driving
a bus or you're a pedestrian
is
be in the moment
be aware of what you're doing at that
time
that's not a time to be
multitasking
it's not a time if if you've got a lot
of things going on at home or things
worrying you that's not a time to be
concerning yourself about those things
you should be focused on what you're
doing on the roadway that way you are
aware of all the variables and
everything that come and confront you
in the process of driving
and the same thing with pedestrians
even when you're in the right-of-way and
crossing a street
it's always the best practice to make
sure you're you're doing those things to
ensure your safety
just because you're in this roadway say
legally doesn't mean you're in the
roadway safely
and so what you want to do is if you're
a pedestrian
is make sure you're having eye contact
with those drivers that are closest to
you
that could be a potential collision
uh make sure that you're that you're
also focused on what you're doing at the
moment your head's not buried on your
phone or you're not having a phone
conversation or
you're you're not occupied by other
things because
if if you're aware of what's going on
around you and something is coming up on
you that is life dangering then you have
the ability to take those steps to get
away from those things
can you tell us
i know you don't you don't know exactly
the person's identity can you tell us
the description
right now the only information i have is
a female possibly in her 30s or sorry a
female possibly in her 40s to 50s but
again at this point we we've not been
able to identify and it was female
driving right it was a it was a female
school district bus driver yes how far
down is that intersection from where we
are
so
the intersection is basically between
here
between this shopping center and cashman
middle school
anything else
no just in they were they were coming
from uh here's elementary school
mills
uh i'm not sure the elementary school
here but the children that were on the
bus were more of
elementary school age than middle school
age and so um that just happened to be
the route that they were coming out of
um
and
that's so i don't believe that it was
involving cashman students he was
involving the elementary school kids